AND DRIFT IT OUT TO
NET, BUT DECIDED TO
GO AHEHE MATTHEWS, DID T
GET ALL OF THAT.
IT GOES WIDE AND NOW LAST EIGHT
E
POINTS.
THAT RIGHT
SIDE.
IT ROLLS TO JOH THAT ONE, DIDN'L
OF IT AND AN EASY SAVE BY TALBOT
>> Chris: SPEZZA WINS THE DR SC.
AUSTON MATTHEWS ON THE POWER
PLAY DOMI SHOOTS AGAIN. TAVARES
CHANGES DIRECTIONS AND BEATS E .
NYLANDER.
FIRES.
SHORT SIDE IN F F GET THE SECOND
POWER PLAY.
THE FIRST WAS JUST 43 SECONDS.
[ Chanting ]O REILLY.
IN FRONT!   AND MATTHEWS HAYES
DOUBLED DOWN AND THE IN
PENCIL AND KASE, BUZZING IN THA,
AUSTON MATTHEWS TIES THE GAME.
IT'S 10 STRAIGHT ON THE ROA
MATTHEWS ANSWERS WIT
RIELLY.
SHOOTING.
SCORHUGHES.
OVER THE LINE...
MATTHEWS SHOOTS, SCORES!
>> Chris: RIELLY ENTERS.
PASS THROUGH.
NOW MARNER. GAME-TYING
GOAL.
AS ROD BRIND'AMOUR's SEEN T T
MORGAN RIELLY. ON A BREAK.
[ Horn ]S HIS GUY
PASSING HE WAS NOT.
AND THAT CREATED THE CHANCE BOL.
FIALA ONE OF THE WILD's BEST
LINES AND GOT THEM ON THE
ICE BUT STURM KNOCKED IT BACK.
KAHKONEN OUT TO PLAY T, FIRES, !
AUSTON MATTHEWS IS THE THE STIC
PEARSON.
LILJEGREN FIRED THAT AND DEMKO
OF IT.SHOOTS,
SCORES!
AUSTON MATTHEWS STRIKES AGAINST,
SAVED BY BACK, MATTHEWS
PICKS IT UP THE
THIRD. BACKHANDER, CHOPPED
AT THERE BY KERFOOT.
NOW TO THE FORECHECK.
MARNER STEALS THE PUCK.
OF THE NET.
MATTHEWS HAD A CHANCE!
THAT WAS STOPPED BY ALLEN INN
FORSLING BACK WITH A DOZEN
SECONDS LEFT!ND MARNER BOTH
WITH GOALS SO FAR IN THE GAMEME
EHLERS FIRES IT BACK IN.
MARNER IN THE SLOT, MITCH MARNER
YEARS IN A ROW REALLY HUNGRY.
BRING SOME ENERGY INTO A
DRESSING ROOM THAT HASRE COMES E
ASSISTS TONIGHT FOR MITCH MARNER
AND
MATTHEWS ONE-TIMER AND THERE IT
HE HAS ROOM.
BRODIE PASSESE